what's the worst that can happen when
you're 20. you lose what you have you're
20. you've got all your life ahead of
you to restart something else I mean how
exciting is that I always knew at 16
when I left school I wanted to be
self-employed I'd done loads of
different side hustles I've always liked
finding ways of making money School
teaches you to go out and find a job to
earn money but it doesn't teach you what
to do with that once you've got it in
this conversation we talk a lot about
business how to build a physical
business how to build an online business
what it really means to think like an
entrepreneur and the skills needed to
survive in the world of business and how
to make this thing that we call passive
income everyone who's young has got time
to make money I don't think people are
aware of how much time they have I'm
probably going to shock you here with
something